well everybody and welcome to today's
webinar today we're going to talk about
gene and protein chemical names and the
aliases of synonyms of other confusing
terms Rana Morris is going to be giving
the webinar this is Peter Cooper and the
directory for the slides and for that
queue a document will be on that FTP
site there and that said go USA
compressed URL will take you there so
I'm going to turn this over to Rana now
and she's going to talk about chemical
and protein and gene names and aliases
hi and welcome this NCBI minute is based
on two insights blog posts on topics
that many users have asked us about
previously I'll show you how to find
those blog posts the end of the
presentation as science progresses what
we call things can change over time gene
symbols protein names that what we call
chemical compounds this can be confusing
not just when conversing about
scientific research but particularly
when looking for and add articles that
have been published over time in this
NCBI minute I'll give a couple of quick
examples about how the use of names and
terms can be confusing show you how NCBI
deals with this issue in house where we
put the information on our webpages so
that others can benefit from our work
and show you some of the FTP files that
you can download if you want to get this
information in bulk two of the main
groups that handle this nomenclature
issues here at NCBI deal specifically
with defining terms for genes and
proteins and chemical compounds a
classic example of a problem with gene
symbols is shown here I found a paper
published in 1999 describing the effect
of a gene product called p21 SDL one and
for different cancer cell lines in 2010
another paper described the gene p21 sip
one in the CML cancer cell line study
two years later
p21 waveone was examined for its effect
with estrogen receptor alpha and six
breast cancer cell lines these genes are
actually the same
there are many papers that have actually
concatenated these terms and various
combinations fit one way one way
one SDL one p20 one sip one it's not
even really just youth based on
evolution of the term through time since
there was a publication back in 1994
which actually concatenated all of the
various possibilities together in one
swell foop last year a publication came
out describing the effect of cdk n1a and
thyroid cancer guess what it's also the
same gene in fact the official genes
symbol is designated by the human gene
nomenclature committee is actually this
CD kn1 a which is the symbol for cyclin
dependent kinase inhibitor 1a all the
other terms that have been used are now
known as aliases or synonyms or also
known as terms for the same gene and
gene product which in this case is a
protein a similar and perhaps more
long-running problem has occurred in the
world of chemicals here's the most
accurate name for a chemical actually
it's the 2d view of the atomic structure
but early in its research life it was
designated with various code terms when
the structure is known it can have an
official nomenclature designated name IU
pack as example and there's often a
registry number designated for it like
this caste registry number over time
this particular compound was identified
as an important one and given a more
easily pronounceable and marketable name
tamoxifen although various companies
decided to sell it sell forms of it
under other names so what do you do with
all this how do you look things up in a
literature search what do you search
with if you actually want to find
something to buy so how does NCBI deal
with this situation we'll start with
genes and proteins we have a curation
group at NCBI called refseq the
reference sequence project this is a
group of curators who examine the
literature and work with collaborators
in the community along with automated
data Gator and gathering processes to
compile a list of terms that have been
used for a particular gene or protein
this includes an officially designated
gene symbol and protein name 1/1 exists
along with all of the other terms that
have been you
Sport and literature and reputable
databases such as unipro PDD and Swift
wrote and from submissions from experts
in the field we display compiled lists
of all of these records in the gene
database gene symbols are shown in the
summary section at the top of the page
with the official gene symbols
designated and others that have been
used are listed in the also known as
section protein names are listed in the
general protein information name section
with an official name designated along
with others shown below here's an
example for the CD KN 118 here's the
gene page for CD KN 1a the human version
just to remind you there is a table of
contents in the gene database on the
right hand side that lists all the
sections on this record in the top
section is the summary which lists the
official genes symbol and protein name
the organization that made this decision
is listed right here in this case this
was decided by the human gene
nomenclature committee the HGN see other
alias gene symbols that have been used
throughout history are listed in the
also known as section further down the
page you'll find the protein names
listed in the general protein
information section under name surname
while the refseq group deals with genes
and proteins we have another group at
ncbi that deals with chemicals the
pubchem group has automated processes
that aggregate all of those terms that
have been used for chemical compounds
aliases are synonyms for chemicals are
compiled from mesh indexing curators at
the NLM and from submitters of chemical
data to pubchem in addition you may
remember from your old organic chemistry
class that there are several different
nomenclatures used for chemicals based
on their atomic structure we have a
software program that will actually
compute these terms based on the
chemical structure these are called
descriptors these include our old friend
or nemesis IU pack as well as several
others such as inchi and shiki smiles
and smart finally we aggregate
identifiers that were used by various
organizations such as the FDA's you
term the II use European chemical
agencies number and others these are
placed on the pubchem compound record
pages in the names and identifiers
section here's an example for tamoxifen
pubchem compound page for tamoxifen is
shown the record has a top summary
section which is pretty helpful pubchem
does put its table of contents on the
left hand side listing all of exceptions
and they are expandable for a
multi-level outlined views in the third
section that lists those names and
identify errs that have been aggregated
and calculated first comes the computed
descriptors which are generated from the
chemical structure IU pack in G intiki
and so on then below that is the other
identifiers list including cash registry
number one we have the information an EC
number and the FDA's unique number for
example then there's a synonym section
including all those compiled by mesh
curators at the NLM and a list collected
from all of these submitters of
information to pubchem note that you can
also download the information in this
record at the top of the page you can
also do this back on the gene record
page but what if you want to download
not just one gene or chemicals
information but a whole bunch of it all
at one time back to genes and proteins
in addition to displaying those also
known as and names directly on the gene
record pages the refseq group also
produces several files that they
regularly update on the NCBI FTP site
these are tab separated files containing
text with lots and lots of information
and includes gene symbols and protein
names among a lot of other cool stuff
they are called
gene info files here's the full path to
find the gene info files on our FTP site
to help visualize this they are located
in the gene directory in the data folder
in the gene info subfolder you can get
the all data gene
info GZ file which provides lots of
information for all the organisms listed
in the teen database alternatively you
can get an organism specific file which
is much smaller and frankly what most
people want for example under Mammalia
subfolder you can select the Homo
sapiens gene info GZ file to get only
the information about human genes notice
that we also have files specifically
designated for Mouse rat dogs etc also
please note that these are pretty large
gzip compressed files
what are these files look like well they
are 15 tab separated columns with lots
of information I've turned the table
over 90 degrees and have shown only a
few columns here because I think it
makes it easier for you to see what they
have here's an example of data
pertaining to that CD kn1 a gene or
cyclin-dependent kinase inhibitor one a
that I showed you earlier showing the
gene database identify our number a
bunch of symbols and then the names
designated for that particular gene
product please note that the organism
specific ones are easily importable into
Excel or parsable with even much more
helpful data about the genes that I'm
not showing you here but you can keep
this car to reorganize those columns in
Excel or by parsing however you want
while gene and protein information is
the charge of the refseq group remember
the chemical information is gathered by
the pubchem group and they are displayed
on the pubchem compound records the
pop-can group also produces helpful FTP
files which are perhaps even more easy
to use to correlate synonyms for
chemical compounds there's a single file
in the NCBI FTP site which actually has
only two tab separated columns with a
pubchem compound identifier or cid in
the first column and then a
corresponding synonym on the second
however if you're interested in all
those other names and terms for
chemicals computer descriptors and
identifier z' you'll need to download a
full pubchem compound database record
file to get those so where are they
here's the full path to find the pubchem
files on our FTP
esight again to help visualize this they
are like located in the pubchem
directory in the compound folder and
then there is an extras folder that has
a whole lot of really nice and helpful
files you can access the cid synonym
filtered gz file down here at the bottom
to get a cleaned list of all the
synonyms provided to pubchem for
chemical compounds the gzip compressed
file is pretty big almost a gigabyte but
it's a simple file containing only two
columns the cid compound identifier and
the synonym there are other files in
this extras folder that may be of
interest such as the cid mesh full file
which shows only the single mesh
preferred term for the chemical which we
use for the name at the top of the
pubchem compound records for all those
other computer descriptors and
identifiers you'll need to go to the
compounds current full record files they
are produced in several formats you can
get whichever one is best for you
asn.1 XML or SDF here's an example of
the portion for the tamoxafin data in an
SDF formatted file embedded in the data
riu path names in Chi in Chi key terms
smiles terms and lots of other data now
you don't have to remember all of this
or even watch this video again if you
don't want to all of this information
has already been written up with
descriptions and links and to NCBI
insights blog posts the NCBI insides
blog provides information about ncbi
resources with tips and tricks to help
you use our site and make cool
discoveries one ncbi incites blog post
fully explains how to get the also known
as terms for genes and proteins another
talks about how to get chemical synonyms
and even mentions simple AP is that you
can use if you prefer to using those
rather than downloading large files i've
included bit ly links here to make them
easy to find but you can always check in
on or search the ncbi incites blog site
for more cool tips and tricks many
helpful how-to videos are and this one
will also be added
to our YouTube channel and as always if
you have any questions about or need
help with our resources please send an
email to our help desk at info at NCBI
NLM NIH gov thanks for your attention
thanks rata we have time for a few
questions I see that there's I answered
one in the question spot that I think
everybody has seen the answer to that
the other one was about work can get a
copy of the slide deck that will be
linked to our webinars and courses page
well actually a bitly link on the cover
of the front slide has it I'll get that
into the questions pot in just a minute
okay we have one more question that's in
the questions part is how often do the
gene and perking database update to fit
in an identifier I'm not sure about the
gene I'll have to get back to you on
that pubchem actually updates those
files every day when new information
comes in it takes a couple of days to
process and then that file is literally
updated every I think of 7:00 p.m. at
night or so so that's constantly updated
I believe the gene record is updated a
little less frequently but still pretty
well and we can find that information
out for you if you send an email into
info at NCBI we'll be happy to get that
information for you and I've sent out
the compressed URL to the FTP site that
has a slide deck to everyone okay and
another listener from NCBI is
chimed in in the question spot the gene
info file on the FTP site seems to be
updated daily as well okay I don't see
any other questions and we're out of
time so I'm going to go ahead and wrap
up the webinar thank you for attending
and Rhonda thank you for providing this
webinar and we'll see you next time